we're locking down a 10 block radius
around the scene no traffic in or out we
think our man is still inside the area
esu is on site i'll be leading the eye
from a mobile command center santiago is
running perimeter control peralta
you're in charge of the manhunt for the
shooter oh my god it's a manhunt
and i'm the man hunter and i'm your
sidekick
the boy hunter come on dude i'm gonna be
on the news i'm gonna look straight into
the camera and say
if the shooter is watching i hope you
like living between saint charles place
and connecticut avenue
i don't get it it's from monopoly that's
where jail is
whatever it was a good line keep reefing
yeah santiago the command tents in the
northeast corner
we need to work fast the mayor's only
giving us five hours until the
barricades are lifted five hours tell
them the manhunter only needs one
love that but i'm gonna keep it at five
it's already way too little time all
right i'm seeing security cameras i need
all that footage
i need forensics to run a full sweep hey
what are all these civilians doing here
who's responsible for securing the area
who screwed this up hi
i'm officer debbie fogle i'm so sorry my
partner's on crowd control i don't know
where he went it's his first week on the
job so he's still learning the ropes all
right listen fogel we have a councilman
in the hospital and his shooter is still
at large we don't have time for this
incompetence i want your partner off the
case what's his name
it's raymond holt oh
it's dad i mean captain holt i mean
captain dad i mean
officer holt i mean officer dad yep that
was it officer dad i found it
clear in the back copy all clear on the
main hall clear
clear the service road a quarter mile
away is also clear
hold on there's a pigeon approaching
hold the mission
[Music]
true great work with that pidge officer
detectives switched to channel five
anyone else getting a sense what's upset
about the new captain coming tomorrow
it's bad this morning to decide for the
entire length of our elevator ride
i wonder who one she's gonna stick us
with this time
clear clear i'm sure it'll be someone
terrible but we've had bad bosses before
and we've always managed to get rid of
them let's just do that again hey listen
i'm taking this weekend off do you think
you can have the new captain gone by
monday i'm kind of over meeting new
people gone by monday
challenge accepted clear
clear
[Music]
you got a runner nypd
taking down the bad guys without
breaking up our convo that's how we do
it in the nine-nine
you're going the wrong direction damn it
all these hallways look the same that
was such a cool walk-off
it's happening again rosa rosa hitchcock
fell asleep in the break room i pranked
him i tied his shoelaces together
38 years old dude i know and yet my
pranks still stay so fresh it's
incredible gotta untie his shoes before
he gets hurt seriously seriously
ugh fine but what's the worst thing that
could happen
he's being shrank on the cabs pow
oh hey jake what's what's the deal with
the office today
it feels crazy somebody stole 20 bricks
of coke and some machine guns from
evidence what it's the first i'm hearing
of it
yeah well you just got here right right
i need you to find whoever did this
and kill them so they're dead
bonkers morning huh so any idea who did
it no but whoever it was had an intimate
knowledge of our security systems
it was obviously an inside job i bet it
was brian
why'd he say that because he once said
he has a hot tub
you know how that crowd is i don't know
brian hit a hot tub that does sound bad
yeah but we have to let the
investigation run its course right now
everyone's a suspect except for
hitchcock and scully whoever did it took
the stairs what'll happen to the person
you know if you find them well they've
committed several felonies probably
looking at uh 30 to life
so that person could miss 15 olympics
cool i have to go
they know the drugs are missing they
don't suspect me because i'm playing it
super cool now when is the handoff yes
i'm alone in the ladies room no one
can hear me okay so i know something but
you can't ask how i know it
debbie took the coke and the guns
acting super suspicious thanks everybody
for coming out to hitchcock's divorce
party why is the cake two men getting
married let's meet hitchcock the boys
are back together this cake is for a gay
wedding
the inside is a rainbow uh-uh it's my
favorite flavor
all the flavors i can't believe
bethany's gone it was so out of the blue
well not entirely i mean she did have an
affair with her hairdresser and you
filmed it and threatened to release the
tape and then she said she didn't care
and put it on the internet herself and
then when it started to make money you
suit her for half the profits
and then boom out of the blue divorce
papers uh buddy you'll be okay
it doesn't feel like it my heart is
ruined forever
i'm done with love i'll never find
anyone who's oh my god get a load of the
can on her
see it dorks i'm gonna get some well
hitchcock still sucks what's this
meeting about did someone find my
meatball sub hey we would never have a
meeting about that b
you are holding it oh mini good journey
meeting's not over dummy terry said he
has some news from the office of
commissioner wunch
ugh what does that human blister want
now does she intend to demote me even
further
or perhaps she'll transfer me to the
swamps of new jersey so i can patrol the
sinkhole where she was spawned or it's
possible the announcement has nothing to
do with you oh good thank you peralta
you're right
maybe madeline wants to inform us all
that she's a chooksy a what a chookson
a korean toilet ghost lives in an
outhouse wraps her hair around your
throat and
chokes you to death while you move your
bowels you know what i will give you six
thousand dollars if the announcement is
she's a chookson
okay everyone i have some news the
madeleine wunsch is a korean toilet
ghost
boring we already knew that madeleine
wunsch
is dead say what now shane reed suspect
in a string of beings got pulled over
this morning
this was in his trunk son of a
[ __ ] peralta rossi calm down
why am i here i didn't do anything you
broke into 15 houses shane but that's
not what i care about right now
all i care about is what we found in
your car i don't understand he doesn't
understand diaz why don't you fill him
in
you are invited to celebrate the wedding
of katherine joyner and douglas judy
douglas judy aka doug judy aka
the pontiac bandit maybe that's a yes
now tell me shane
when did you get the invite what when
did you receive the invite in the mail
and how come i didn't get one
why would you get an invite do you know
doug hey i'm the one asking the
questions here
calm down jake maybe it's a small
wedding okay good point how big is the
venue
shane i said how big is the venue i i
don't know
i i i i don't know but i bet you do know
the password to the wedding website
don't you yeah i guess
well then i guess you better tell it to
me shane you wash my back i'll wash
yours
i'm in scratch you know i meant scratch
now tell me the password i think it's
doug and kate forever
was that so hard shane you did the right
thing now get this piece of trash out of
my sight
oh is forever spelled out or is it the
number four oh it's spelled out
okay thank you so much now get this
piece of trash out of my sight
and i believe that's all i've got oh
wait there's one more thing
peralta gave me a note before the
meeting
ugh the penmanship is horrid but i think
it says
ask if anyone has an anal mint it's
announcements and we do
wow what an entrance amy and i have some
big news to share
i'm pregnant we're pregnant
what the hell i thought you guys would
be more excited than that charles you
didn't even faint
i'm so sorry i'll try
it's not working somebody took me on it
rosa sorry we're so happy for you but we
also maybe kind of already knew i mean
you didn't do the best job of hiding it
why have you been carrying that box
around so much i just love this box
why are you reading that newspaper it's
two days old i just love this issue
hey why are you wearing that hazmat suit
i just love this look
okay fine so you all knew we were
pregnant good for you but i bet you
didn't figure out that we're having
twins no not really it's one baby i just
needed to see charles faint
i don't miss porzingis i'm glad that
nick's got rid of him that's crazy you
never trade a seven footer with
three-point range
[Music]
why is the precinct full of bunnies
this is still going on what is
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
halloween heist
can you believe this scully looks like
we're the only responsible people who
show up on time anymore and they're
always calling us lazy
but where are they now i don't see them
they're not here but you know who is
hitchcock and scully the oafs the bozos
the idiots
what are you doing here the building's
being fumigated there were so many
emails
there were we did
lightweight that's your takeaway and
those of you patrolling 7th avenue
please be aware of the new pedal pups
they're bike-powered mobile bars that
are very popular with bachelorette
parties but unfortunately they have led
to a dramatic
increase in the rarely seen case of
female public urination resist
that's everything but before we go home
quick reminder that today
is sergeant santiago's last day before
maternity leave yes
we'll see you in three months can you
get three months off can i take a
maternity leave
are you giving birth to a baby i'm
having a seven pound mass removed from
my abdomen next week oh
yeah never ask scully questions that's
on me guys dismissed
so have you guys decided on a name yet
we're not telling people until he's
bored not the baby's name my name what
are you going to call me uncle chuck
monkey c
ooh chi-chi so he says it early maybe
just charles wait so my dad gets to be
his pop-pop but i'm just charles
your dad does not get to be his pop-up
well i hope you're prepared to make that
phone call
uh what was that wow oh brooklyn lost
power
you know i've always kind of liked
blackouts listen how quiet it is it's so
peaceful
nope it immediately turned into a purge
way to go new york all right let's suit
up
you